Queen Alison has not forgotten the love
you once had for each other
no blood need be spilled hey guys Pete
here today I'll be talking about the
final episode of House of the dragon's
first season it was titled The Black
Queen though dragon's gonna Dragon might
have been more fitting a few weeks ago
after beceros passed I read an excerpt
from Fire and Blood where I had to leave
out the last sentence because it
described what was coming at the end of
the season now that we're here let's
revisit that it reads then viserys of
House Targaryen the first of his name
King of the Andals the rhoynar and the
first men lord of the Seven Kingdoms and
protector of the realm closed his eyes
and went to sleep he never woke he was
52 years old and had reigned over most
of Westeros for 26 years then the storm
broke and the dragons danced if you're
thinking I don't know if I would call
what we saw happen to Luke at the end of
this episode a dance you're not alone
Arts maester gildane the fictional
character who wrote the Targaryen
histories described it like this to
characterize the dark turbulent bloody
doings of this period as it dance
strikes us as grotesquely inappropriate
no doubt the phrase originated with some
singer most of season one functioned as
a prologue to establish the characters
who will be at the center of that dance
and lay out the events that made it
inevitable those events are all tied to
King beceros the first Reign he ascended
the Iron Throne at the height of house
targaryen's power in a long period of
peace and prosperity he was an
indecisive but mostly likable character
that perhaps tried too hard to hold on
to that piece we came to understand that
viserys lived a life defined by guilt
and remorse over the death of his first
wife Emma and how his obsession with
prophecy was connected to that and the
decisions that he made as king more
importantly we meet his daughter and
named aaronira in her childhood friend
and daughter of the hand of the king
Allison Hightower we're first introduced
to them when they're about the same age
as Luke is when he takes his fateful
flight to Storm's end we see the bond
that they had back then and watch them
grow up and then see how they were
positioned to be at odds with each other
after his death in the finale we had a
great reminder of their Connection in
the form of a torn out page from a
history book it's a heartfelt gesture
that makes you wonder if things could be
different while at the same time it's a
tool being used in an attempt to
manipulate a situation it's fascinating
and it is something that I'll come back
around to at the very end of the video
the final two episodes of the Season go
together and focus on the two different
parties vying for power in the wake of
viserys's death in episode 9 we saw how
Allison responded to what she believed
was her husband's dying wish to see
their son aegon Ascend the iron throne
in a showdown at Dragonstone that
mirrors the one that rhaenyra had 20
years prior with Damon Otto lays out
what they hope to achieve by acting
before she found out about her father's
death coming into the finale aegon
Targaryen II sits on the Iron Throne he
wears the conqueror's crown wields the
conqueror's sword has to conqueror's
name and he was anointed by accepting of
the faith before the eyes of thousands
this reminds me of varys's conversation
with Tyrion in the original series where
he tells him power resides where men
believe it resides it's a trick a shadow
on a wall and from the capital in a seat
that was forged from the swords of his
House's Fallen enemies even an unfit
young mess of a man can cast a very
large Shadow Alison's faction whom I'll
be referring to as the greens has put
Rainier's faction whom I'll be referring
to as the blacks on their back foot and
the other thing season one of this
adaptation did was establish that the
whole situation is somewhat more
complicated than readers of the book may
have thought thought it was
Fire and Blood is written as a fictional
history it retells the events of this
period of time years after they happened
based on conflicting accounts from
unreliable chroniclers it's essentially
propaganda filtered through their
perspectives and the show sets out to
paint a more complete picture of what
happened is this story about two obscene
the entitled people fighting over how
big of a piece of the pie they get is it
about the Insidious misogyny that
affects them even in their rarified
stations is it about the real power
behind them that props them up and uses
them as puppets is it about protecting
your family and your legacy is it a
tragic tale that shows us that all this
happened because of an ill-time
misunderstanding or is it a complicated
mess made up of bits and pieces of all
those things the source material leaves
this open for interpretation and the
show seems to be leaning towards it
being all of the above the finale Valley
opens with renera's Second Son luceris
valarian looking at the island of
driftmark on the painted table at
Dragonstone this is something fans of
the original series will recognize and
Luke's problem here is that he's
concerned he isn't up to the task that
his duty and Birthright demands if Lord
Corliss doesn't recover from his
injuries this scene connects with the
conversation he had with his Grand sire
back in episode 7 when he said he didn't
want to be his Heir because if he were
the Lord of driftmark that would mean
everyone else was dead that episode set
up a lot of what comes to a head in this
final one it highlighted the
generational nature of how these
families cling to power how the parents
count on their children to continue
their legacies and how they use them in
their plotting with little regard to how
it might affect them this was also when
Eamon traded his eye for the largest
dragon in the world and when things move
past what felt like a point of no return
between rhaenyra and Allison when Luke
confesses that he doesn't think he has
what it takes to be the lord of the
tides his mother tells him that we don't
get to choose our destiny and that she
wasn't ready to be the queen of the
Seven Kingdoms when she was named Heir
at his age either as she reassures him
that she'll help him grow into that role
Rainey survives fresh off her escape
from King's Landing she brings her the
double dose of bad news that not only
has her father died but her half-brother
has been crowned King initially rhaenys
isn't there to get involved she even
clarifies why she didn't act in the
dragon pit saying it wasn't her War to
start because relations seem to be
improving between renera and Allison on
her recent visit this all does come as a
genuine surprise Damon comes to the
conclusion that the greens killed his
brother and usurped his wife's claim
raniera can't believe that Alison asked
rhaenys to bend Anita aegon and the
stress of all that's happening sends her
into labor which is concerning to the
maester because it's very premature and
while she struggles through the pain of
that Damon goes into military mode with
the other concerned parties that are
gathered there Jason Luke are in the
middle of a training session and it
stands out that Jace is pretty hard on
his younger brother which may end up
Weighing on him down the road
considering how things turn out they get
called inside to learn about everything
that's happening and you can see that
they want to do their part Damon hears
his wife calling out for him but Ops to
continue planning he also stares down
sir Laurent when he asks if he wants to
go speak to the maester to check on her
when Jace comes in to tell him that
Ranier doesn't want anyone to act while
she's in bed he takes him outside to
watch him give the two members of the
kingsguard a chance to swear their
loyalty to their side this is a tricky
situation for them that is made all the
more uncomfortable by the fact that
caraxi's is standing right behind him
as Sir Stefan darklin points out he
first swares oath to jaharis and then
again for viserys when he ascended in
that role they were assigned to his
daughter who they know he named as his
Heir that means that if they side with
raniera they'll be considered traitors
by the people who are currently holding
King's Landing it's a great way to
underline the way this succession crisis
affects everyone and goes hand in hand
with rainey's killing a bunch of small
folks as she was escaping the dragon pit
as sworn soars these two could lose
their lives right here or later if they
find themselves on the losing side of
things as could all of the families that
are standing around the table with Damon
there are inherent benefits that sway
the Lords to one side or the other and
there are real risks if they end up on
the losing side these are the stakes and
even though Allison does offer rhaenyra
terms that would let her keep
Dragonstone and pass it down through her
line where Luke would get to fulfill his
role as the lord of the tides and her
other children would be incorporated
into aegon II's court she would find
herself in the same situation Allison
was in before her children would never
truly be safe as potential replacements
for the current King the moment he did
something to turn powerful Lords against
him which to be fair seems to be
inevitable given his background there
would be calls to remove him I do think
Alison is sincere in thinking this is a
workable solution I think sending the
page from the book she's kept for all
those years reinforces that but she's
blinded to the reality of how people
will react now that the shoe is on the
other foot and as I mentioned at the
beginning this is a calculated political
move runyo fights her way through a
brutal stillbirth delivery we see her
take this on almost completely by
herself which is in direct contrast to
what we watched Emma endure in episode 1
where the choice of how to proceed with
her complications was taken away from
her watching renira is what would have
been her sixth child and first daughter
evokes the conversation she had with her
mother where she explained that the
birthing bed was their Battlefield this
is a gripping sequence with another
powerful performance by Emma Darcy
that's topped off with a heart-wrenching
scene of her preparing the body for
burning herself as they say goodbye sir
Eric arrives to pledge himself to her
cause he presents her with viserys's
crown that he managed to get out of
King's Landing Damon crowns her as Queen
raniera first of her name and everyone
present bends the knee to her except for
princess rhaenys who we'll find out
later is waiting to see how her husband
reacts to everything he missed out on
when she returns to the painted table to
assume her role in lead we get an idea
of what the blacks are up against they
do have a small force that is sufficient
enough to defend Dragonstone which is
well fortified but isn't enough to mount
an invasion the fact that rhaenyra is
interested in exploring other are
options in rages Damon who wants to make
the high Towers pay immediately by his
math they have more dragons than the
greens and they should use that
advantage to take back the throne
raniero responds by citing some history
that came down from her father in
relation to Old valyria when dragons
flew to war everything burned I do not
wish to rule over a kingdom of Ash and
Bone and while this is another blow to
Damon who is having a hard time holding
back it does win over Prince's rhaenys
who is impressed with her restraint and
will lead to her bringing the sea snake
on board for team black and she had to
bring him out of retirement to do that
after his injury and after she lets him
have it for abandoning his family for
six years to go play at war after they
lost Lena and Lenor he was ready to
enter his Sunset phase and live out his
days playing with their grandkids she
reminds him that they are all caught up
in what's happening and I guess we're
supposed to understand and that after
she heard both pitches from Allison in
episode 9 and raniera here she likes the
idea of not ruling over ashes more than
gently guiding The Men Who rule from the
sidelines to skip ahead briefly when
Corley survives it's a huge boost
because he brings with him the largest
Fleet in the world and news that he
managed to really conquer the stepstones
this time which I imagine would cause
viserys to turn over in his grave if he
had been buried rather than cremated by
Dragon but this is all to say that they
could shut down the waters around the
capitol to blockade King's Landing Damon
has plans to take harrenhal so that he
can set up a base of operations on the
continent and we know that the Lord of
that castle now is Lara strong who
spends most of his time in King's
Landing Corliss points out that this
would make for a good start but doesn't
add up to a force that could win a war
yet it says in the book that even if you
combined all the hosts of all the houses
that are already pledged to their side
died they still wouldn't be able to
match the power the high Towers alone
could field this is why the idea of
pledging banners is so important in
Westeros all of these Lords have their
own armies so their support matters plus
the greens have control over the largest
and richest cities in the realm in Old
Town King's Landing and lannis Port if
it comes down to war renero will need to
ensure the backing of several of the
other major houses that bend the knee to
her when she was named air the plan is
for Jace to fly north stopping first in
the Erie and then on to meet with the
Starks at Winterfell Luke will take the
shorter and presumably safer trip to
Storm's end where his mother believes he
will receive a warm welcome she has them
swear on a copy of the seven-pointed
star that they'll go as envoys rather
than Warriors and won't take part in any
fighting and it really feels like an
ominous sign when he calls her mother
before correcting himself and saying
your grace before we get into what
happens I want to just briefly recap how
the two sides stack up at the end of the
first season the greens have a king who
sits on the Iron Throne that was crowned
in front of tens of thousands of people
at his coronation hundreds if not
thousands of small folk were killed by a
dragon whose Rider has now joined the
other team even though Allison believes
she's acting in accordance with her
husband's dying wishes no one else
believes that including aegon staunch's
supporters they are usurpers but they're
counting on people preferring the male
air and overlooking their transgressions
they hold the Capital control the
biggest cities with some of the richest
families and also have control of the
royal treasury which they split up and
hid for safekeeping they have The
Dowager Queen the mother of the King's
first male Heir and her father who
served as hand of the king for the last
two Targaryen rulers they have the
largest dragon in the world in Vega and
two other adults with riders in Sunfire
and dream fire who are written by aegon
and Helena the blacks have a
well-fortified position at Dragonstone
they have the world's most powerful navy
and the richest family in Westeros on
their side raniera was her father's
named air but there are plenty of people
who would refute that claim based on the
fact that she's a woman going into this
episode they had at least five adult
dragons with riders since the show
hasn't mentioned if Bayla has started to
ride Moon Dancer yet raniera has cyrex
Damon has craxies rhaenys has melees
Jace has Vermax and Luke has arax there
are also several riderless dragons that
live in and around the dragon mount on
Dragonstone in this episode we watched
as Damon pay to visit and sang a song in
High Valerian to Burma Thor which is the
largest living Dragon after vegar
although as far as we know this isn't
really change anything until they have
someone to ride them vermouthor was King
jaharas's Mount his wife Queen alisane's
Dragon Silver Wing is also there and lay
Norse Dragon sea smoke but it's not
clear if another Rider can claim that
one since their Rider isn't really dead
there are also more unclaimed dragons
that have never had riders that they
know of of course having a mountain full
of dragons is not the same as having a
stable full of horses not just anyone
can claim them Reina and the really
small kids are the only ones in the
family who don't already have one and as
we'll find out at Storm's end going to
war on dragons involves putting their
children at risk so about that this
final sequence started out looking
fantastic with rainy striding to patrol
the gullet Jace flying North and little
Luke heading south having the mature
Dragon there to emphasize how small
a-raq still is sets the stage and then
after he lands it's downright
frightening when you get the reveal that
vegar is already there and let that size
difference set in the greens have gotten
to borrow speratheon first and Eamonn
was available to marry one of his
daughters to form a marriage pact the
call for his family to remember the oath
his father made falls on deaf ears and
while I think they did show that
rhaenyra did a more than capable job
leading through most of what happened a
lot about this trip to storms and feels
like it could have been planned better
because he's an inexperienced kid Luke
just looks dejected and turns to leave
Eamon takes this as an opportunity to
try to even the score for the eye that
Luke took from him and demands that he
cuts out one of his he takes off his eye
patch to reveal this giant Sapphire he
wears in his eye socket for extra style
points and unsurprisingly Luke refuses
his demand Lord boros also doesn't want
to see this Prince on Prince violence
under his roof this is something that
would be frowned upon because they are
his guests so he tells them to take Take
It Outside basically at this point the
storm is Raging Luke tries to calm arax
as much as he can before they take off
but I think we should keep in mind that
he is completely afraid as anyone would
be in his position and according to the
lore it's believed that dragons are able
to sense their Riders emotions the way
this scene plays out is somewhat
different than how I interpreted it from
the book and that telling Eamonn is
provoked when one of the Baratheon
daughters who he didn't pick questions
his masculinity by asking if Luke took
one of his eyes or one of his balls
after he leaves he storms out right
after that and then no one knows what
happened other than the dragons were
fighting in the sky and that Luke died
as a result he goes back to King's
Landing and matter of factly states that
he killed him and that makes Eamon seem
like a kinslaying psycho here he just
seems to be trying to terrorize him he
may have wanted to take his eye but it's
clear that he doesn't want to kill him
right before it happens the problem is
that on some level viserys was right
when he said the idea that they
controlled the dragons is an illusion
they're a power that man should have
never trifled with one that brought
valyria its Doom their magical and
majestic creatures but they're also
powerful weapons we're reminded here
that they have minds of their own and
they can't always be controlled I made a
comment about how much I liked that
viserys quote in my episode 1 video and
the one from renera that preceded it
where she says everyone says targaryens
are closer to Gods than to men but they
say that because of our Dragons without
them we're just like everyone else all
of these characters grew up in a time
where their power as a family stood
unopposed for that reason it's what king
jaharis knew and why he called the Great
Council of 101 AC to let the Lords of
the Seven Kingdoms decide on his
contested succession and it's at the end
of that opening flashback where we get
that other key line saying that the only
thing that could tear down the house of
the Dragon was itself when both sides of
a conflict have dragons the stakes are
redefined the way things play out here
is that a-rox appears to get scared and
tries to burn Veigar she responds in
kind biting the much smaller dragon in
Two And as far as I can tell swallows
Luke hole in the process as mentioned
you can tell by his reaction that this
is not what Eamon intended it's still
his fault for chasing after him in the
first place but the idea that things got
out of control adds a layer to the
situation what's interesting is that if
he were to tell the truth about what
happened he'd have to admit that he
can't control his Dragon it makes me
wonder if he might not lie in order to
keep that a secret is it better to be a
kinslayer who showed their enemies
they're not to be messed with or to be
someone who can't be trusted to take
their dragon into battle I mean we are
talking about a young man a second son
no less the that's out to prove himself
so I guess we'll have to wait until
season two to find out how he handles
that either way it makes him a more
complex character than if he just rage
murdered his nephew over something that
happened when they were kids one thing
that's certain is that Luke's death
changes everything in the book it says
and with his death the war of Ravens and
envoys and marriage packs came to an end
and the war of Fire and Blood began in
Earnest the episode and season end with
a scene that starts in silence Damon
approaches the painted table in slow
motion the shot tracks him from behind
as he makes his way from the door over
to Rainier's side we can't see his face
but she can and it looks like she picks
up on something before he opens his
mouth they turn toward the fireplace and
we see that what he tells her shakes her
off her balance causing her to stumble
in the end she turns and Emma Darcy
delivers a face that tells us that
everything will change for this
character from from this moment on an
indiscriminate mix of pain and anger and
loss and rage and then it cuts to Black
I really enjoyed this finale it's up
there with the other top episodes I
thought stood out from what turned out
to be a pretty solid introductory season
overall going in episodes four seven and
eight were my favorites and I would put
this right there next to them I still
think the performances the costuming and
the production design are the foundation
of why this show works as well as it
does the painted table lit From Below
was a great looking addition and getting
a better look at Storm's end has me
excited to visit other westerosi
locations as this conflict gets bigger
this was Emma Darcy's episode much in
the same way that episode 9 was Olivia
cooks and they delivered a memorable
performance of rhaenyra that required
such a wide range of emotions to be
packed into this one single hour she
lost her father she lost her claim she
lost an unborn child only to be crowned
by her husband who later chokes her out
and then she loses another child by the
end of the episode and I think you can
see that war lives in that look that she
delivered at the end there and how all
of those things conspired to bring her
to that place the other performance that
was surprising was the young man who
played Luke Elliott grahal I thought he
did a terrific job in all of his key
scenes I mentioned before that I don't
pay that much attention to the CGI as
long as it doesn't take away from
everything else that's happening I'm
pretty okay with it and I think the show
has done that pretty effectively
throughout this season but I have to say
that this episode is on a different
level all of the shots of bagar in the
clouds and when they clear the storm
looked amazing and the detail of how
arax was responding to the situation and
to Luke really seems spot on they even
managed to make Eamon Sapphire cool with
something I wasn't expecting I've been
mixed on some of the choices they made
in this first season but didn't feel
like any of them undermined the
strengths of the story having seen the
whole season now I think I'd like to
change with Eamon the most if you'd even
call it a change because in world the
only person who really knows what
happened is Eamon I can understand a
knee-jerk reaction to this not matching
up with who you thought the character
was I do experience that whenever they
change things from the book when I'm
watching or if it makes it a little less
convenient to hate the greens if that's
what you're into but I think if you
think it through it makes the character
more interesting it gives them more
options on what they can do with him and
it doesn't really change the larger
story it still starts the war and it
highlights how when things start moving
in that direction they're nearly
impossible to stop no one's actions are
without consequences here including
Eamon and he's just out there acting on
behalf of his family plus the dragons
being out of their control does seem
like a foundational element to the whole
thing with their family the reason they
have their power is because of those
creatures and you think about the
corruptable nature of power when it
comes to something like becoming a king
but think about giving a small selection
of teenagers dragons and what that might
do to them another thing I liked about
this episode was that there was a lot of
facial acting going on between Matt
Smith and Emma Darcy they passed a lot
of information silently I thought this
worked to sell the escalation of tension
building up between them in a subtle way
it's a bit tricky because it's hard to
tell where they're at at different times
but in the end I think they pulled it
off you can watch as Damon tries to take
control of the situation and steer
everything toward War it makes sense for
him he has a long history with Otto and
he believes that they killed his brother
and stole his wife's claim I think it
also comes across that he's starting to
see more of viserys and rhaenira than
the person he wants her to be and I
liked how the C team with vermouth or
work to highlight the differences in how
they were reacting to the situation and
on some level who they are as
individuals there's so much in this
episode that matches up with Allison's
journey through episode 9 and I find it
really surprising to see how similar
Damon's role is to Autos I think it's
clear that he wants renera to be a
dragon in the same way he wanted his
brother to be and it really sets him off
to see her favoring her father when she
brought up the prophecy another thing
his brother kept from him I thought it
tracked for the character to explode
after what we watched building up it's a
choice to have him choke her rather than
Express his rage in a different way but
we know he's a violent guy and that his
statement about being capable of
depravity was part of the reason she
wanted him on her side and that's not to
say that she thought he was capable of
doing something like this to her because
I think when you watch her reaction you
can see that she is shocked at it and so
I think that will make it interesting to
see how things change between them now
that we you've reached this point my
takeaway from this story was never that
it was about picking one side over the
other I've never considered myself a
supporter of Team black or Team Green
sure raniera has the better claim and
the characters on her side are more
interesting in the book but it always
seemed like a tragic tale of how
everyone suffers when powerful people
don't get what they think they deserve
the system they're born into dictates
that something like this is inevitable
and yet the power involved is so great
that it still draws people to do things
they might not do otherwise in an
attempt to possess it also it is
generational the kids get pulled right
into it they don't really have a choice
it happened to viserys and rhaenys it
happened to rhaenyra and Allison and now
we see that being passed down to the
Next Generation the show has managed to
add to that in its first season it's
been able to humanize the characters who
bring all of this fire and blood into
the world they end the season with the
death of a child who is only trying to
do right by his mother and his family he
was born into this rather than choosing
this as I mentioned at the beginning
he's about the same age as Ranier and
Allison were when they were in the
godswood reading that history book about
nymeria that the page on the bridge came
from back when she was still her
father's cup Bearer before she became
Heir and before Allison's father sent
her to comfort the king in his Chambers
after Emma's death they were born into
this system too the monarchy that is
backed up by the threat of violence from
their dragons that keeps them in a
position of power above everyone else
and the patriarchy that ensures that
their role as women is limited to what
others are willing to grant them and it
all amounts to a recipe for disaster and
again I liked how they split these two
episodes to show how that played out on
both sides we got to see Otto and Damon
both try to take control and escalate
their respective situations and Allison
and raniera trying to find a peaceful
solution there was a brief moment where
you can imagine that cooler heads might
Prevail a glimmer of hope that you might
be able to fix a broken system by
installing the right ruler renera sheds
a tear when she sees the page and
remembers that the 14 year old laying in
the grass next to the Heart Tree is
still inside her and that that part of
Allison is still in there too what's
tragic is that as viewers we know that
while that's probably true they've been
absorbed into the system that created
them as sincere as the gesture and the
feeling might have been it was still a
move from someone who's playing the game
and maybe there was a time when they
could have found a way to avoid war but
that time passed when Luke died it's an
interesting thought to end a season on
and I think that's a great place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought about this episode and
what you thought about the first season
in general I had my issues which I stand
by but it was a lot of fun and there
were some real high points in this
season so not perfect but I'm looking
forward to more how are you feeling
about three more seasons and what are
you gonna do until
2024 when we get more episodes please
like this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon